season four of ballers is on HBO 10:00
p.m. on Sundays and he's just been
picked up for yet another season dwayne
johnson also in this show with my next
guest rob corddry good to see you sir
Congrats did you see yeah thank you just
heard yesterday just seems like some
much fun guys have yeah it's exactly as
much fun as you think it is it's a it's
just you know I think not just because
the cast is so cool I think it's also
because the guys running the show
Steve Levinson in particular they're
just so chill about the whole like
they've done this before yeah so it's a
relaxed environment they're not stressed
about anything at least not on the
outwardly well I guess if anything that
could go haywire wine or haywire on
Entourage who's the best acting athlete
that you've had on that show oh my god
well there's been very few bad
well technically ting John David
Washington with a cup of coffee with the
st. Louis Rams and some pre seasons
would technically qualify or not you
know he had a jersey he did yeah
his dad showed up to the NFL Network a
couple of times because he could not get
the st. Louis Rams preseason games in
his home seasons like I got to go to
where the games are and he showed up
amazing yeah so who's the best one that
you've um God who's well I would
probably have to say T sizzle Terrell
Suggs man cuz that guy is like he
improvises really likes one of the best
improvisers I've ever seen and then but
then you the camera where they call cut
and he's still going like the guy just
never stud he doesn't have an off button
he is he is a large human being he is
who wants to do this for a living uh
yeah well or produce this is my story
yeah I agree like Victor Cruz also said
the same thing to me that like yeah this
is cool man I wouldn't mind doing
something like this and he was good too
right and uh you know I'd realized
there's only been one or two that I can
count that that have been a little rough
around the edges but they're I think
they get there and they're nervous their
first take right mm-hm
and then they realize how much easier
my job is than their job you can't
really die doing my job your head does
not need to be on a swivel now you know
I'm not gonna tear an ACL popping
Achilles and then normally stories are
ripped straight from the headlines but
on on this season's on this season
you're you fired the general manager the
Rams less need getting fired essentially
on the show yeah sure
you know I mean we have that much power
that's kind of not happening you know in
the real life but yet we brought it we
brought the Raiders to a Vegas - you
didn't hear that amazing you really guys
you guys can really make things go you
need what do you want what do you want
to happen
I know make it happen we're right it in
so Rob Corddry here on the Rich Eisen
show your your outlook on the Patriots
season is what what do you think oh my
god I was I was talking about this
earlier well I'm they'll probably get
they'll probably they'll definitely make
the Superbowl I think they'll get there
around week six they'll win the Super
Bowl week six week seven maybe you know
be it'll be wrapped by this by weeks
yeah I think that'll bit It's A Wrap
It's A Wrap on the season now why are
you why am i pagers from that area yeah
I think that's the only reason to be a
fan of the bad guys so you know China
Brockman my resident New England owner
Rob is trying to say that a Patriots are
the new America's team just because
they're red white and blue I'm also
going I'm talking myself into this we
unite the country via hate they all
everyone else yes hates us
all 31 other teams all 31 other fan
bases what other team can you say that
about so your unites not divider exactly
yeah yeah I mean I don't buy that at all
this is a world in which dad laughed
when I even read it gave the sense that
they would even be considered in there
they are you nighters unites and hate
I love rooting for the bad guys I love
it because I've always been a Red Sox
fan I wasn't like a big football fan
when I was a little kid yeah but the Red
Sox were always the underdogs everybody
loved the Red Sox and I
couldn't understand why anybody won't be
a Yankee fan they're very bad guys and
now I get it right it's fun so you don't
shoot during football season director oh
no we don't so well we start sort of at
the end starting like January so January
February are you guys watching playoff
games together like you and Dwayne
Johnson ever sit oh yeah what we do is
we have love seats yeah we all sit and
love seats and there's like a groove
worn out in the love seat where we all
hold hands each other
grapes nachos which is the romance
romantic of well food right cuz Dwayne
Johnson was SAP's roommate at the you
way back in the day I was he really oh
yes oh that's cool they know each other
from that far back ballers season for
HBO 10:00 p.m. Eastern on HBO okay
you're you just wrote this piece about
being a better dad right for men's
health that's right correct
that's right how can you help people in
the Rich Eisen show viewing and
listening audience be a better dad you
have certain well you might my whole
premise with that article was that the
best way to be a better dad is to be
super selfish okay you know basically
just do it cuz it's not easy with a
little little kid on a Saturday and you
got him all day to like fill that time
and all you want to do is take a nap
after hour - so you want to fill your
day fill their day with things that you
like to do yes but you just got to
change the context a little bit how so
what do you got for me um I like to
drive so what I would do is I would
drive around my neighborhood and play
this game with my kids called let's get
lost and they would just go right left
left right and we would they think mmm
they were so nervous the whole time like
daddy what if we really get lost like I
I don't know I don't know what's gonna
happen this is what you are doing with
your children then we'll play let's get
found this is what I do yeah it was fun
it was really let's go get lost okay no
I've seen some pretty cool stuff now in
this in this city because
I'll teach them gambling is something as
well but yeah okay and that's actually
something while I'd written that I
hadn't done as much but we went to we're
in Wyoming a couple weeks ago and my
wife had to go do something I forget
what so it was just me and the kids and
I had a pack of cards and I taught them
how to play blackjack I taught them how
to bat when to maybe up your bat mm-hmm
and this this old couple looking at us
across the restaurant and the woman is
just staring like burning a hole in my
in my head he just he looked at me and I
kind of gave him a glance and he went
out of boy and they're good too they're
good gamblers they're good you know
basic strategy blackjack okay have you
ever you incorporated your children in
any of your fantasy leagues have you
done anything like that no they're not
you know what actually last last night
of all mites the worst game in NFL
history yeah so boy I'm gonna fall
asleep here just thinking about it but
wait my daughter my youngest daughter
came in for the first time was like
daddy can I watch football with you how
old is she no she's seven eight okay no
she's nine she's between six and ten
[Music]
she's nine she's not okay um and and
this is the first time and I've tried to
convince her that football is her thing
I was like telling her that the running
backs take ballet lessons I'm like look
there's a spin there's a spin and she
never got it but now she's into it she's
comparing with me okay she managed to
find places to cheer last night is that
amazing epiphany for you right yeah it's
pretty exciting now do you get any sort
of pressure about watching games in the
house because not everyone's into it or
you know no you know they're really cool
about I would rather they I would love
if they all just sat with me and now
they do sometimes they'll come down we
play this game this is how I'll get him
to do it we'll all sit you were sitting
on the couch just will play the
commercial game so in a commercials on
in the line they have to buy the first
thing you know ok I really have to buy
it right making my kids get GEICO
insurance dishwasher you know and that's
how it works that's how you get them all
involved that's so far yeah we we like
we'll get Chinese food and eat it around
I I'm trying to scam them but it looks
like it's starting to take with the
little one it's amazing yeah so
thankfully this game hasn't been played
where there has been something you need
to consult you just consult your doctor
before you use it for three hours
yes for sure oh yeah all the time what
is it what is viagra daddy
oh god that question is such well sit
down kids let me explain to you well
first things first is you got to get
separate tubs and then you take a
football and throw it through a tire
while water flows snoring let's play
start bench cut with with Rob Corddry
okay I give you three choices you have
to start one bench one and cut one okay
hey that's the this one there's no
marriage or anything like that no
there's none of that it's it's similar
but you know it's a start
you can kiss and cut if you work yes
okay here we go
start cut bet start bench cut first one
the three choices Tom Brady Jimmy
Garoppolo Carson Wentz quarterback you'd
like to have leading your team in the
next five years
Bradon Garoppolo Wentz for the next five
start bench cut over the next five years
the next five that's tricky isn't it
it's a trick question it's no it's it's
one that makes you have to think it
really and that's what you and now you
know
everybody in Boston's like whatsit kind
of beer up hot Cod's what's it gonna be
pal you're not you're not gonna say when
sigh yeah cuz Brady's gonna play til
he's 75 I'm gonna start Brady yes
I'm gonna start Brady yeah you're gonna
bench wince and how do ya do it's a kiss
he gets the kissing cut okay here we go
second one for Rob Corddry person who
sports career you would like to have Tom
Brady
David Ortiz Larry Bird start bench cut
sports career you would like to have man
I'd have to say start David Ortiz what
because he's just so I feel like I could
be friends with him in a way that I
probably couldn't be friends with Brady
okay that's what it's all about
friendship yeah right that's the way you
want to view the prison
sports career you'd like to have yeah
that's great and then I would um and
then I would I would have to cut Larry
hmm because you know he's got a job now
he's gonna be okay having my sports
career okay and then yeah bench Brady
alright last one for you last start
bench cut for Rob Corddry person who's
acting career you would like to have Oh
start bench cut Rob Corddry start bench
cut here are the three choices don't say
we're a go Rob Corddry dwayne johnson or
the rock that's good
alright you know it was the wrong choice
different thing this sort of like Kobe
wore number eight and number 24 yeah I
would start Rob Corddry I'm cool with
this okay he works too hard you know
yeah yeah you know what I'm gonna do one
when I leave here what nothing you know
what he's doing right now like five
different things on a plane you know
like I don't know is he is he is he he's
benched
I'll Bentham you pit which which one are
you gonna bench the
we're the bench and Dwayne cut in the
rock because I think part of him
probably wouldn't mind that back start
bench cut with Rob Corddry that was fun
there you go tough mean question yeah
that's mean quick really mean me you're
ripping at the fabric Sports soul yeah
you knew it I put in these issues before
- you knew what you were doing eyes and
you know what they wouldn't they
wouldn't be fun if they were easy what
did you say we have we have gorgeous
fantasy team - go for it this is the one
from my main league right here
everyone's got a league that they want
and I think I'm going to once once gets
better cuz suffer suffer through my
cubies and then get to the good part how
many team league how many team this is
at ten ten team is it and it's a half
point PPR okay very few quarterback
League quarterbacks oh my gosh okay
the name of your team peace and love and
Eileen no that's that's the name of the
Li love and I leave Blake bortles as one
of your quarterbacks oh I don't know how
you can defend that Rob Corddry yeah
it's better than look at the waiver
where okay give me this team Nick Foles
and Carson Wentz you're going to Dublin
up there okay well you have Michael
Thomas Mike Evans Doug Baldwin okay Todd
Gurley Devonta Freeman Evan Engram
Golden Tate I like it good it's good if
I like it the QB things just got to work
itself like so you had question marks so
first week of your team it's a it was a
bortles foals double dip here right yeah
and boy worked really hey but you got
receiving yards from Falls last night I
know I did seven point seven points
that's also ten percent of his points
for the way I got killed and the guy was
playing had a je je like the one out of
two guys that scored a respectable
fantasy he's got 18 points
so said your daughter chose that night
to come in seems not to have known what
was going on thank God good to see you
rob to see you please come back anytime
hey wait Jameson Crowder or Emmanuel
Sanders to start my other way
[Music]
Jameson no no no no
Jameson Crowder yeah is that who's is
Peterson I'm gonna be on him that's the
whole thing if Patrick Peterson is gonna
be on Jameson Crowder look that up I
don't know right now off the top of my
head but if it cuz me because his slot
right over he's gonna throw it
everywhere yeah I'm telling you I have
no idea what case games gonna look like
I don't know I think you're right all
right thank you that's my advice to you
and if it's a if it's Emmanuel Sanders
then whatever Rob Corddry with two DS
and two R's on Twitter good to see you
sir that couldn't have been the first
time you ever heard that right double
D's yeah actually it was the first time
maybe like a year ago okay I was like oh
yeah double D's I have been wasting that
opportunity the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience